- But it it's hard for me not to parent,
not just the kids, but
the grownups on the show.
I mean, you
saw me like sit up.
- I mean you just told me
to sit up straight.
- Yeah.
- That's right.
You're a ballerina so.
A ballerina, people.
I read about you.
- That's always my stylist.
Well, were you a ballerina?
- You didn't know this?
- Yeah, but you know what?
That's long in the past.
I am not fit capable
whatsoever these days.
- Wait, wait, wait.
Do a
(speaking in French)
- I will not,
- I will not.
You will not.
(audience cheering)
- She said, lunge, lunge.
- I love it.
(audience cheering)
Oh my God.
- Wait, wait, wait,
wait, you read about her?
- I read up.
- You're just gonna
skim over that?
- I'm just gonna
skim over that.
- Listen, listen, listen,
listen, I missed my connecting
flight the other day in Utah
and I only had to run through one terminal
and by the time I got to the
end, I thought I was gonna die.
I was like, I will never run again.
- That's also called almost 40.
That's what it's also called.
- I pulled my back out this morning.
- Lifting a chair
- And I can't breathe
fully without spasming
- Oh my God.
- which is why
I'm sitting here like.
- Yeah.
- I'll tell you something,
once you get to my age,
you do a sneeze
- Age is beautiful.
- and you like, first
of all wet your pants.
- That's also having children.
- I still do that.
- Yes, thank you, girl.
- Oh my God, there's no segue.